nous avons besoin que vous entriez, laissez-moi mettre votre
main où voulez-vous que je sois un
grand fan de la veuve noire et j'adore
jouer ce personnage et pour moi,
m'habiller à nouveau était juste assez
excitant la veuve noire quand nous avons
trouvé pour la première fois  elle recrute le médecin de l'équipe,
nous avons besoin que vous veniez et si je dis non,
je vous persuaderai que Black Widow est tellement
apte et tellement douée que si nous pensions qu'elle
devrait faire partie de l'équipe, je vous apporte
la fête  Je ne vois pas en quoi c'est
une fête, je pense que tous ces personnages
sont en quelque sorte des super-héros réticents dans un
sens, un grand homme en armure de costume, enlève ça
, qu'est-ce que tu es un philanthrope playboy milliardaire de génie,
tous ces
personnages se réunissent dans un monde
c'est  très excitant les Avengers c'est
ce que nous appelons nous-mêmes
les héros les plus puissants de la Terre
vous